LET'S GO, SNELLY!
RUN ALL OVER THEIR ASSES.
- COME ON.
- YEAH, MAN, RIP HIS ( bleep )
HEAD OFF!
- ( crunching )
- ( man grunting )
( all gasping )
( dramatic music plays )
WHAT?
WHY WOULD YOU SAY THAT?
I DIDN'T THINK HE'D DO IT, MAN.
I WAS JUST IN THE MOMENT.
Announcer:
This is truly the worst thing
to happen in sports.
Nobody-- I don't care how
big a fan you are--
nobody wants to see this
happen to the rival team.
HEY, MAN, WHEN I YELLED THAT,
YOU ALL CHEERED.
ALL RIGHT?  YOU'RE ALL GUILTY.
YOU WANTED THIS.
NO, YOU DID THIS!
SHAME ON YOU.
HEY, MAN, HE YELLED, "RUN ALL
OVER THEIR ASSES," OKAY?
REMEMBER THAT EARLIER?
AND YOU CHEERED.  NOT COOL.
YOU CAN'T DIE FROM THAT.
THAT GUY RIPPED
THE DUDE'S HEAD OFF.
ALL RIGHT, TEAM.
WE GOT A CALL, SOMEBODY HERE
JUST YELLED,
"RIP HIS HEAD OFF."
I DIDN'T MEAN FOR IT
TO HAPPEN.
COME ON, BUDDY.
LET'S GO.
YEAH, GET THAT PSYCHO
OUT OF HERE!
YEAH, RIP HIS HEAD OFF.
- ( bones crunching )
- ( man screams )
- ( all gasp )
- DEAR GOD.
WHO JUST YELLED THAT?
STOP YELLING THAT.